well well Marcus spoon the prodigal it
said a mr. Albert since that's the least
I can do
then you must be Nick boomer says you
got a machine that can brute force any
combination lock certainly can dick just
gotta get a little time
Nick mendosa right a lot of people want
to talk to you Mendoza including a
fellow from La named Stoddard say he'd
pay 250 grand you alive he's coming here
right now
boys what do you say we escort mr.
Mendoza and Marcus down to the
presidential wait you said just Nick
welcome here be number one killer up
this [ __ ] before I puke
Marcus just so we're clear face is not
factored here my dislike of you is 50%
[Music]
everybody on me and Melhem creative
director on battlefield hardline and I'm
here to give you the first look at our
single-player campaign I've relatively
good news really would you get that
do it give me Charlie dude who just set
us up dude who said you were Shi Zhai
people oh sure
now the visceral battlefield
single-player is quite distinct
alright stay behind me you'll notice how
the pacing is very different and so is
the experience we gotta find a way out
of here
made no argument here hell is this place
anyway missile silo decommission in
early nineties do just party on here
please tell me up it doesn't happen uber
they don't have a nuke that I know of
back to remind that all of us here with
this the wholesale integration rolling
deep of tearing down Oh
everything that make this country great
you know in college class you know what
they say place
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
how many uh running around yeah
now Benny hang back let me handle this
hey do you think man
Mexicans hippies some [ __ ] dude I
don't know what he was once Tony took
over he changed the whole scene pronto
as you can see you can get through a lot
of our game by non-lethal kids you
decide the way you want to play so who's
he got paying the cops bounty Tony
doesn't know found his number on the the
ATF agents phone how tor a million bucks
for a Mexican she I didn't know they got
so expensive for example check playing
stealth you're always looking for ways
to isolate your enemies here we're using
a bullet casing to lure one of these
goons away from the group to better our
odds
these [ __ ] have bad skin hey there's
a letter that's the way out yeah come on
[Music]
all right I need to get our gear back
what are you nuts
let's just get out of here look if
starter gets his hands on it he'll trace
it right back to kaien Tyson okay we
can't risk that
[ __ ] all right so how you want to take
this man there's a lot of Albert's dudes
down there looks like there's a place to
climb in on the left
or we could crawl under that fence over
here all right
yeah or we could take them head-on if
you're up for that and you lead I'll be
right behind you
what a thought fortunately let's just go
come on you look at this black man kid I
feel it now we're using a new gadget the
scanner to stake out the situation you
can find objects weapons alarms tagged
enemies and identify targets
Nik
this is another new feature called
freeze by managing it writing you're
able to freeze enemies and prevents the
situation from escalating with the book
okay I don't follow those guys I found
that my hands are up
alright yeah I do nothing all right I
don't want no trouble okay
looks like your old friends have gone
way past bank robbery one black
president and Tony completely lost this
[ __ ] is a radio look imma try to reach
dude [ __ ] don't you have any other
friends
not out here
okay I'll get it to the compound and
find our gear all right hey careful
telling you you ain't ever gonna get the
hold about your spark plug insulator
tips are cracked I just changed them no
one must swap them out the Taser is a
great example of a non-lethal gadget
that is effective in stealth mode
you think mine
what the hell
here's our high-value target arresting
these perps will give you a huge bonus
now we're gonna head in grab our gear
and try to hook back up with boomer now
take a nice long alright just one time
to get out of here
fully flaps will stock and a modified
grip for maximum shooter comfort while
spitting roughly
right there hands up you're gonna ride
that gear never off hey who you with man
CIA FBI I know who you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
where'd it go
choice is really going to change up the
experience it's up to you to choose your
path our single player is going to
deliver great new immersive experience
and really add to the depth of
battlefield hardline
you